e
mais bon
le mont beuvray dans le morvan est une
montagne aujourd'hui presque entièrement
recouverte par une forêt de hêtres et de
résineux comment imaginer qu au temps
des gaulois au 1er siècle avant notre
ère les et du 1
un des peuples les plus puissants du
monde celtique y avaient établi leur
capital bibracte protégée par un mur
d'enceinte l'oppidum traduction latine
de ville fortifiée abrite est à son
apogée
une population estimée entre 5000 et
10000 habitants
les gaulois n'ont pas laissé de trace
écrite nous remonterons donc le temps
avec la guerre des gaules de jules césar
qui inscrit bibracte dans l'histoire
les fouilles du 19e siècle révèle
ensuite les premières fondations de
l'oppidum aujourd'hui bibracte est
devenu un des lieux incontournables de
la recherche archéologique
des archéologues de toute l'europe
celtique y travaille au musée
les plus belles pièces trouvées sur le
terrain permet au public d'imaginer la
vie quotidienne des habitants de la
ville gauloise
suivant un groupe de scolaires et
laissons-nous compter sur le terrain
l'histoire de bibracte
bibracte était donc la capitale des et
de 1,1 des peuples les plus riches de la
gaule il faut pour se figurer cette
ville dit à 2000 en faire abstraction de
tous ces arbres il n'y avait pas d'arbre
à l'époque
ici on pense d'ailleurs que le morvan
était beaucoup moins boisé il y a deux
mille ans qu'aujourd'hui
voilà ici on arrive au centre ville avec
échauffent bâtiments publics pour tout
ça on commentera plus en détail lors de
la descente
vous savez bien sûr que jules césar
séjourner ici il a passé l'hiver 51
avant jésus-christ il y aurait rédigé
une partie de ces commentaires
conseillons bibracte nbc tour jules
césar évoque ici l'assemblée des grands
chefs parce que vercingétorix a été élu
chef de l'unité gauloise ici à vivre al
on vient ici pour les deux côtés le côté
nature le côté ambiance est côté
sciences archéologiques trouve toujours
son bonheur à bibracte finalement
alors autant vous le dire tout de suite
ce bassin c'est une énigme
c'est aussi un unique où mme jusqu'à
présent dans l'état actuel des
recherches
c'est le seul bassin de cette forme aux
blondes qui a été mis au jour
deuxième chose c'est là l'orientation du
bassin puisque le milieu du bassin et
positionner en fonction des solstices il
correspond à l'est au lever du soleil le
jour du solstice d'hiver et à l'ouest au
coucher du soleil le jour du solstice
d'été
les gaulois et mais les grands
rassemblements sous ces tapis de
feuilles les ruines d'un temple ou d'un
forum dorment peut-être encore bibracte
aurait pu disparaître de la mémoire des
hommes car la ville a laissé des
vestiges modeste pas de ruines
monumentales comme en grèce ou en italie
les archéologues interroge les traces
laissées par les architectures bois de
la ville si on relit entre les trous
laissés par les piliers porteurs les
fondations des maisons du bibracte se
dessine sur le sol les est due à un
appartenait la civilisation celtique les
peuples celtes avait une culture commune
il pratiquait de nombreux échanges
commerciaux mais chaque peuple était
indépendant au niveau politique
jules césar proconsul romain a de
grandes ambitions politiques pour
asseoir sa renommée il profite un
événement majeur de l'année 58 avant
jésus-christ la migration des helvètes
l'ensemble du peuple helvète 300000
personnes a décidé de quitter son
territoire
la suisse d'aujourd'hui pour la
saintonge la charente actuelle
voyage long et périlleux qui bouleverse
les équilibres politiques du monde
celtique césar attaque les helvètes et
les écrase à 26 km au sud de bibracte
est quad à bibracte et hôpitaux à edou
aurum longue et maximo et de copies aux
issimo nonne en plis youth miliboo ce
passe ou des cannettes
octo à berat réis froome hunt arié
prospeed thiendou existe hymne à 8
quand césar dit qu' on était à deux
jours du moment il fallait donner le
ravitaillement à ses soldats le
règlement de l'armée romaine implique
que pour par jour et par soldat on lui
donne un peu plus d'un kilo de blé à
chaque soldat et quand il part en
campagne il a dans son sac à dos environ
pour 15 jours d'autonomie le reste les
légumes la viande ils se débrouillaient
hippique dans les fermes
il chasse mais l'armée ne s'engagent
qu'à donner des céréales c'est tout or
césar quand il court derrière les alv
être là il est avec trente mille hommes
plus vraisemblablement autant de
personnel qui s'occupe des attelages et
cetera du ravitaillement
donc mettons qui ne nourrissent que ces
trente mille soldats
vous multipliez ça mettons uniquement
par un kilo on est déjà à 30 tonnes jour
trente deux jours or césar leur demande
aux et demain de livres et ce à tous les
quinze jours donc 30 par 15 on est à 450
tonnes 450 tonnes de céréales qui sont
stockés dans des grands greniers sur
l'oppidum du beuvray donc ça pour nous
c'est la preuve que dans les années donc
50 60
le pin homme est déjà équipé des normes
grenier qui permettent le stockage et ça
a été relativement confirmée par les
fouilles archéologiques c'est à dire que
tout ce qui est autour du beuvray est
évidemment culture
mais le spécialiste des macros restes
végétaux a même trouvé des mauvaises
herbes
dans les céréales qu'on trouve sur le
site et ses mauvaises herbes sont des
mauvaises herbes de pays calcaire ça
veut dire que le ravitaillement en blé
couvre une surface qui va jusqu'à la
vallée de la saône au moins donc quand
un oppidum récupère comme ça des
céréales c'est sur un territoire qui est
son territoire global
jules césar a fait entrer bibracte dans
la mémoire historique
mais il restait la question de la
localisation de la ville tout le monde
s'était mis d'accord pour situer
bibracte à autun mais c'était sans
compter avec jacques gabriel bulliot qui
sillonnait le morvan à la recherche des
traces de saint martin
quand lee berger amener leurs troupeaux
ou des bêtes qui passait sur sur le
chemin on entendait bien distinctement
que ça ce n'est pas de la même manière
sur le chemin et sur le talus et quand
bulliot est arrivé sur le site du
beuvray dans les années 1850 il s'est
fait conduire par un paysan qui lui a
montré un petit peu voilà il cherchait
la croix de saint martin donc qui
voulait se faire indiquer cet endroit
donc on l'a emmené là bas mais le paysan
lui a fait faire aussi le tour de ces
talus et le paysan lui dit avant il y
avait une ville très très grande
elle était si grande la ville que quand
on ouvrait les portes on entendait
grincer les portes jusqu'à nevers
c'est ce qu'on lui dit ah bulliot quand
on fait se promener autour de ces talus
et voilà sur cet endroit où
effectivement on voit pas grand chose
d'autre de la nature en fait on lui
raconte une autre histoire
après les talus les paysans indiqua
jacques gabriel bulliot des vestiges
d'important l'homme de lettres acquiert
alors la certitude que bibracte se situe
sur le mont beuvray
il convainc napoléon iii d'entreprendre
des fouilles à grande échelle
elle commence en 1867
les fouilles dégageront un premier
rempart de 5 km et des quartiers
d'habitation le long d'un axe central
nord-sud en 1897
le neveu de jacques gabriel bulliot
joseph déchelette prend sa succession
le premier guide de tourisme et
d'archéologie paraît en 1903 par contre
à la proche de la grande guerre de 1914
les fouilles s'arrête pendant plus de 70
ans
le mont beuvray n'est pas abandonné pour
autant malgré ses pentes abruptes le
beuvray a accueilli jusqu'au xxème
siècle des foires et des fêtes annuelles
dont les processions de la chapelle
saint martin un concours de
circonstances favorables va permettre la
reprise des fouilles l'élection à la
présidence de la république de françois
mitterrand qui aiment le mont beuvray
permet d'inscrire bibracte dans la liste
des grands travaux d'état à l'époque
françois mitterrand était conseiller
général donc et et du château chinon
dont il avait déjà envisagé de racheter
le site et ensuite lors de son élection
l'an jack lang a décidé poussé bien sûr
par toute la nouvelle génération
d'archéologues qui s'était formée depuis
le temps qu depuis un certain nombre
d'années a relancé l'archéologie en
fruits en vain chantier exemplaire avec
aussi un programme derrière les jeunes
les jeunes et l'histoire c'est à dire
aussi ré expliquer l'histoire
remonterait d'histoire aux jeunes
dans ce cas on se retrouveront 84 à pau
fouillé double vrai la particularité de
la flûte bibracte a été tout de suite se
dire on ne foulera pas tout seul on va
fouiller à plusieurs et on va ouvrir la
fouille à tous les collègues étrangers
et français s'intéressent donc très vite
on s'est retrouvé dans une communauté
d'archéologues qui étaient intéressés
par l'europe ses tics
mais combien est belle image
d'énigmatiques pour un visiteur que
celle de cette équipe tchèque et
slovaque qui sont dans le brouillard le
sous-sol du beuvray en émettant des
ondes électromagnétiques ou en analysant
les déviations du champ magnétique
terrestre
les échos de ces ondes sont ensuite
étudiés par des moyens informatiques au
centre de recherche de bibracte
ce qui est intéressant c'est que nos
convois certain nombre de structures qui
apparaissent des structures qui était
déjà connu puisque fouillé soit au 19e
siècle soit plus récemment mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on a également
donc des structures qui n'était
absolument pas connu comme c'est lé mans
circulaire donc ça qui est intéressant
est que ces méthodes géophysiques c'est
que ça permet de savoir où est-ce qu'on
peut aller justement fouillé notamment
pour vérifier toutes ces structures qui
apparaissent
le rempart reconstituer et des chantiers
de fouilles accessibles permettent au
visiteur d'imaginer une ville qui se
révèle petit à petit
l'établissement de bibracte développe
également tout un projet pédagogique en
direction du public scolaire
on
regardes et tu grattes bien avec le
truel
si la ligne elle est blanche c'est
sûrement un oui et si c'est orange et si
c'est noir voilà maintenant tous et
comment faire oui ça c'est quoi dubois
alors attention
le bois est ce qui peut se conserver non
il se conserve seulement quand il est
brûlé
donc c'est du charbon que cela fait
quand la production donc dans l'eau
est-ce que là on est dans l'eau est-ce
que ça s'est brûlé marigarde il est
brûlé non donc ça veut dire qu'ils
essaient de caen ça date de quand
aujourd'hui on est dans une forêt c'est
normal ça comment moi je veux dire
regarde autour de toi est ce qu'il peut
y avoir plein de branches de racine des
choses comme ça mais voilà tout le métro
et seront concernés dans toujours on ne
déplace jamais rien un conte fait le
ménage dans une fouille on ne cache rien
sous le tapis hier on met tous d'assaut
la chose la plus importante c'est de
faire agir les élèves pour comprendre la
démarche d'archéologie ici les fouilles
on fête cette année les 30 ans de le
premier coup de pioche des fouilles
moderne donc forcément ce qui est
important c'est que tout passe par
l'observation est tous passés par la
démarche de la recherche en ce qui
concerne la pédagogie les élèves qui
sont ici ils sont en séjour
donc il reste trois jours à bibracte
mont qu'ils ont le temps de découvrir le
site en faisant une visite de balade et
puis ensuite de pouvoir expérimenter
comment les archéologues arrive à faire
parler les objets à faire parler les
vestiges pour comprendre et reconstruire
la vie quotidienne dans le passé
le mobilier archéologique trouver dans
les fouilles et conservés dans des
espaces à l'abri de la lumière avec une
température et une hydrométrie constante
ils sont ensuite lavé et analysées afin
qu'ils soient à jamais sauvegardez pour
la recherche scientifique
ces objets sont précieux car ce sont les
seuls liens qui nous rattache aux
habitants de bibracte qui n'ont pas
laissé de textes écrits juste quelques
bribes en alphabet grec sur des poteries
ça va ça va regarder en train de
préparer les bois qu'on va en apposant
son je suis en train de changer l'eau et
de les laver et ensuite on les remettra
dans les bacs on les remettra à l'abri
de la luminosité pour pâques les micro
organismes ne se développe jusqu'à ce
qu'on les emmène
et puis on pourra aller les étudier ces
jolies on voit toute l'estrie indus et
du bois ou les fils venait oui c'est
beau parce qu'il ya tout leur et
collages et c'est le seul métier à
tisser en bois qu'on connaît en gaule
andriat fou qui sait tout jeune
chercheur italien rédige une thèse sur
l' architecture bois de bibracte
il s'entretient avec vincent guichard le
directeur de l'établissement et en
organisation rationnelle de la
production des éléments en bois qui sont
content qu'ils ont utilisés pour la
construction
donc on a vraiment une production sous
large échelle de les madriers les
poutres les sont conquis son qui sont
utilisés on a rarement façon de
construire à bibracte qui est très
organisé très rationnel donc on n'est
pas dans les cas de l'individu qui
récupère les bois dans la forêt pour se
construire la maison on est dans le
cadre d'une réactivité on peut dire
presque une économie de la production
des bois et de la mise en oeuvre du bois
donc une économie de la construction du
bâti du bâtiment de l'habitat demi
tracts
on a une filière bois clairement c'est à
dire que les bois étaient choisissez des
déserts parfaitement droit qu'on allait
chercher non pas sur les pentes du mont
beuvray mais en pleine des arbres qui
ont un fils de voix très régulier qui
peut être facilement et carrie et on a
même l'impression qu'on sortait des des
bois avec des gabarits déjà prêtera ses
dires comme le marchand de bois avec les
poteaux porteurs qu'ils aient 10 cm par
vingt deux sections à peu près les
planches qui sont des grosses planches
de 3 cm d'épaisseur qui était le plus
haut possible
voilà donc on a au travers de cet
exemple de l'architecturé bois c'est
tout un modèle économique qui est en
train de contraindre surgir le musée de
bibracte est l'oeuvre de l'architecte
pierre louis faloci qui a obtenu pour
cet ouvrage en 1996 lekker d'argent la
plus haute distinction française en
matière d'architecturé la nouvelle
muséographie de bibracte met en scène
les trente dernières années de fouilles
1 le métier d'archéologue et la
recherche scientifique sont explicités
le visiteur est sollicité par des
installations des vidéos des maquettes
l'ensemble les savants et ludique tous
les publics peuvent y trouver leur
compte
une nouvelle figure du gaulois se
dessine au fur et à mesure de la visite
e
nous voici maintenant dans la galerie
inférieure du musée de bibracte qui
présente l'un après l'autre les
différents secteurs de la ville gauloise
on va retrouver à chaque fois la
restitution de vestiges archéologiques
tels que les archéologues les ont vus en
fouille des vestiges qui sont restitués
à l'échelle 1 donc en dimension réelle
l'exemple le présenter ici c'est celui
d'un atelier de bronzier qui comme on
voit est composé de deux espaces un
espace sombre vont travailler le métal
on le faisait fondre dans des creusets
on avait comme souci d'avoir une
perception extrêmement précise et fidèle
de la température du feu et du métal en
fusion ce qui explique le caractère très
sombre du sol de cette partie de
l'atelier en avant la deuxième partie
l'atelier un espace beaucoup plus clair
plus on finissait le travail des objets
dans cet atelier ont fabriqué pour
l'essentiel des fibules donc c'est à
graf qui servait à maintenir les étoffes
du vêtement des fibules qui étaient
fabriqués ici selon un procédé
standardisé
à
les celtes se sont peu représentées
bibracte conserve néanmoins une tête en
granit autres et à peine ébauchés d'une
sobriété toute contemporaine
mais l'art celtique c'est avant tout
exprimer dans des objets utilitaires
d'une grande richesse esthétique
autre source les pièces de monnaie
les celtes se sont appropriés des
modèles grecque et ce sont représenté de
profil de manière spécifique est très
différente des animaux fétiches esquissé
sur le côté pile des pièces peuvent être
utilisés jusqu'à l'extrême
on se rend compte qu'il ya assez peu
finalement deux types d'animaux
représentait donc qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour nous ça veut dire qu'il ya
vraiment une sélection d'animaux qui a
été fait par exemple on ne représente
pas de lièvre ne représente pas de
poisson a donc là on sent qu'il ya
vraiment tout un langage également
derrière alors ce petit sanglier qui
hélas a été découvert au 19e siècle sur
les pentes du mont beuvray
on voit qu'il est complètement tendu là
la crête hérisset et des poils qui vont
être dressée comme les chats en colère
et puis alors une que 1 absolument au
somptueux stressé inquiet qui est comme
ça qui fait une boucle sur son
arrière-train on sent bien là
l'intention très clair ça va être
vraiment l'agressivité du sans billet
qui est mis en exergue
si on choisissait signes agressifs c'est
parce que là on est dans un symbole
guerrier
m
pour m
le
on peut vraiment se demander pourquoi on
dépense tant d'énergie depuis 150 ans
pour les exhumer ces pauvres tessons de
poterie du sol de bibracte 1 ça fait la
durée des fouilles et plus long que la
durée d'existence de la ville c'est un
des paradoxes
la ville a été fréquenté pendant habité
pendant un siècle et nous ça fait un
siècle et demi qu'on est cons et là
pourquoi on fait on fait ça j'irai
d'abord par la simple curiosité
scientifique à prendre appréhendé un
moment de notre passé qui est totalement
in appréhendable par les textes
il faut les gratter le sol pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé à l'époque
de césar et avant l'époque de césar n'y
a pas d'autres moyens alors évidemment
les bribes du passé que l'on récupère
sont dérisoires ces tessons de poterie
parle pas l'archéologue essaye de faire
parler les objets mais c'était très
difficile
n'empêche ce sont les seuls témoignages
concrets et ils ont beaucoup de valeur
parce que c'est la façon dont on a de se
mettre en lien avec ses prédécesseurs
d'il ya 2000 ans je parle de
prédécesseurs et pas d'ancêtres ça pas
beaucoup de sens de parler dans cette
quand il ya 60 à 80 génération qui nous
qui nous séparent de cette époque
notre histoire elle commence aux gaulois
on peut pas remonter plus loin en temps
il n'ya pas de peuple auquel on puisse
donner un nom avant l'époque de bibracte
donc quand on va cette fête cette quête
des origines
eh bien on bute toujours sur la fin de
l'âge du fer sur l'époque de
vercingétorix main d'où l'importance
qu'a pris cette époque dans le récit des
origines et le récit des origines c'est
ce qui nous fait notre identité
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui fait l'identité
de la nation française c'est peut-être
un peu ce qui fait l'identité européenne
donc ces gaulois prennent une place
importante dans ses discours sur
l'identité parce que ce sont les les
plus anciens auxquels on peut on peut
donner un nom venir à bibracte c'est
faire l'expérience du temps c'est
percevoir l'écho lointain d'une
civilisation qui a laissé peu de traces
matérielles
le site n'a pas encore révélé tous ses
secrets
15 % seulement des terrains ont été
fouillés ou prospecter au fil des
campagnes de fouilles les archéologues
de l'europe celtique reconstitue le
puzzle d'une histoire qui réserve encore
bien des mystères
m
e
à